[Musique]
mais
depuis l'année 1974 quinze mille camions
soit quarante mille français s'adonnent
au camping car un homme à 10 mhz
structure est un moyen terme entre le
chez soi et l'hôtel venant des états
unis cette nouvelle vague de campeurs en
autocaravane traduisez campine cas
commencent à envahir nos routes 12
constructeurs viennent de voir le jour
en six mois et vendre leurs maisons
ambulantes entre 50000 et 150 mille
francs le camping-car permet une évasion
beaucoup plus autonome
c'est un moyen de tourisme très
indépendant qui au contraire des
caravanes évite le stationnement dans
les camps futilement avec un camping-car
vous pouvez stationner ou vous voulez
dans les rues sur des places sur une
plage sommet du montagne vous stationnez
absolument où vous voulez moi
j'appellerai ça plutôt un mode de vie
une façon de voir
la vie sous un autre angle c'est à dire
une façon de s'évader des villes d'une
vie
très très très très envahissant très
structuré le camping-car n'exige que le
permis tourisme au contraire détracteurs
de caravanes donc ne pas dépasser pour
l'instant trois tonnes 5 quant aux mères
de famille il était légitime de leur
demander leur avis sur cette nouvelle
forme de loisir c'est beaucoup plus
exigus on a beaucoup moins de ménages à
faire puis pour les reports dans se
contente d'être un petit pic tech 1
légumes en face c'est plus facile nous
n'avons que par exemple un mois de
vacances et nous allons très loin avec
beaucoup plus de facilité de liberté
nous faisant huit à dix mille kilomètres
par an pendant ce mois là eh bien vous
ne pouvez pas le faire avec une petite
voiture ou est-ce que vous allez avec le
camping car j'allais de l'eau marron oui
seul nom avec quelques
j'ai déjà fait 16 pays
lorsqu on peut stationner n'importe où
pourquoi ne pas prendre sa douche en
plein paris
[Musique]